[Music]
thanks for coming today guys
your quick wins leveraging GCP for rapid
prototypes as mentioned - Patrick with
technical business analyst here - Gus
though on the advanced services team by
my side here got Ray Pittman he's our
solution architect also with the
advanced services team we're not
familiar with the gusto we're a Tier one
GCP partner we are located in the
Minneapolis Minnesota
so our HQ is if you have any questions
about a gust or you just want to learn
more feel free to stop by our booth
13:21 it's got the big red a above it so
pretty easy to spot moving along so
today what are we gonna talk about we're
gonna talk a little bit about some of
our customer stories what did they do
what issues did they did they have and
how did we help them solve those those
issues after that we're going to review
some of the architecture trends there's
a really two different use case two
different types of projects that we're
gonna review so we're gonna look at the
architecture trends amongst those types
of projects we're gonna hand it off to
Ray then he's gonna review some of the
common services that we're using on
these rapid prototypes before I move on
here though I just want to get a quick
idea of where everyone in the audience
is at with GCP so I guess first question
who knows what GC P stands for okay good
all right we're off to a good start so
who's using GC p in production right now
or you're well on your way okay cool
good how about if you're evaluating GC p
maybe you're on your way but it's still
kind of new couple hands all right cool
good I got two mixed people here so so
that's good last question so some of you
might know twelve animals of the lunar
calendar I don't know if anyone's
familiar with that here
how many of you know what Year 2019 is
what animal it represents the year of
the pig so once we learn that coming
from Minnesota we we couldn't pass up
the opportunity to talk about one of our
favorite clients and their
internet-connected pigs
a project that we more affectionately
referred to as the Internet of swine so
you might be wondering why would someone
want to connect their pigs to the
Internet it seems a little bit weird we
thought it was a little bit strange when
we first were approached with this
opportunity but see our clients is an Ag
tech company and they saw an opportunity
to to help farms improve their
efficiency and increase revenue
they knew that they spend a lot of times
monitoring the health of pigs right for
reproductive reasons and they're also
very prone to get sick so if they could
track their activity and build a
predictive data model around it they
could help the farm hands save time so
they had a hardware team that managed
the the embedded development so I'm
gonna review the hardware here they
brought us in to really help with the
cloud infrastructure so we're gonna look
at the app architecture right after this
but just so you understand how the data
was getting to the cloud let's let's
take a look at the hardware so first
we've got the ear tag your tag was
attached directly to the pig it had an
accelerometer in it and that
accelerometer tracked their movement so
that they could tell if they were
sitting standing laying down all of the
above it would also collect the beacon
information which is the the middle
there so the beacons were placed in the
feeding troughs and in the water
reservoirs and they would transmit a
signal and the ear tags would measure
that RSSI and if it got close enough it
would then collect the beacon
information and send it up to the
Raspberry Pi which is the third item
there on the right that was just hung in
the rafters of the barns connected with
the ear tags via bluetooth and then
acted as a bridge up to the cloud so now
that you understand how the data was
getting there let's look at what we did
once it was in the cloud so as mentioned
got the pig here representing the ear
tags connecting to the Raspberry Pi with
Bluetooth the Raspberry Pi was then
transmitting the data into the cloud
using an MQTT bridge so initially that
was with RabbitMQ and a custom-built iot
adapter that augusto developed nowadays
that's replaced with IOT core so once
the event data is landed in pub/sub or
in the cloud excuse me we throw it into
a pub subtopic which can then be
consumed by a gke kubernetes engine in
this case kubernetes then did some data
transformation and wrote it to bigquery
for some additional analytics and their
data team to be able to pull out and do
some visualization tools and build their
data models they also see data stored up
there that was just a simple back backup
storage in case there was any errors
writing it to bigquery and we stored the
raw event data in datastore so well the
last thing here that I want to touch on
is just the power of kubernetes I'm sure
you guys have heard about it all next
but once we got this up and running we
really found out quickly that one pod
was not going to be enough to handle
hundreds of devices coming in per second
from all of the pigs in the barn so we
were able to make a quick contact update
scale it up to three pods that was just
for one deployment to be able to spread
out the the workload across all those
pods so ultimately this is this is kind
of what their visualizations started to
look like they pulled it out and we're
able to tell when they're sitting and
both when they're drinking amongst a
wide breadth of other data models that
they were able to successfully build
around reproductive and like if they're
nesting if they're ready to give birth
things like that
so in just over two weeks they were able
to get up and running successfully from
the barn all the way to the cloud in
order to build their data models so it's
pretty quick and we were able to do it
leveraging those those cloud native
services so that's just one example of
IOT we're gonna look at another one here
it's a little bit different than
monitoring pigs so there's our
manufacturing and technology company and
this manufacturing technology company
they have a series of devices that help
organizations of all shapes and sizes
manage and monitor their inventory one
example is actually the badge they have
a some printers so the
they help print the badges on your on
your next certificate or your next badge
this this week so in order to help them
manage that inventory they wanted a
scalable IT solution again they had they
had the manufacturing down and their own
development teams that were managing the
firmware on these on this hardware but
they needed something scalable and in
the cloud so here we come with GCP over
just three weeks were able to get this
this architecture up and running it was
an initial POC in which once we were
actually wrapped with this they selected
GCP as their cloud provider of choice
because we were able to prove out that
it can scale rapidly and to the to the
size that they need so again very
similar to the pigs here got the device
on the left hand side communicating with
IOT core via MQTT bridge from that MQTT
bridge we land it in pub/sub instead of
gke here we have it communicate or being
consumed by a cloud function so it's
just another computer option for you
guys for cloud functions and then
landing it in bigquery for a data
warehouse after they selected GCP we
added some additional functionality so
that's not this isn't within the three
weeks this extra functionality but you
can see it's kind of a daisy-chained
pub/sub quad functions and what it's
essentially doing is doing a lookup into
fire store which is where they're
storing some additional ancillary data
and if there was filter related to that
event that came in they landed in the
cloud function apply those filters if
the filters were were passed then he
throw it in another pub/sub q2 then
eventually notify this web hook and the
web hooks were dynamic so it could be an
infinite number of web hooks one example
are our customer used to demonstrate to
their customers was changing a Philips
hue light bulb color so from red to
green to blue you name it so it's uh two
examples here of two different IOT
architectures pretty different use cases
so you might be wondering like how does
this help you
and if you don't have an IOT
architecture it might not directly but
when you start to strip away some of the
specific tools that are being used and
you genericized is a parka texture you
can start to see some of the trends that
we're talking about here so moving
forward here back to the Internet of
swine
we've got IOT core and you've got pub
sub so IOT core and pub cellar acting
yards you ingest an event cue from there
you've got it landing in the compute and
then bigquery is for analytics datastore
is your backup storage if we compare
this to the inventory and operations got
IOT core and pub sub they're acting as
your ingest and event queue thought
functions as your compute and big
queries your analytics looks pretty
similar
so when you when you start to map that
out you can kind of draw a generic
diagram of this nature right so you got
your IOT devices whether it's a light
bulb a speaker a tablet a gateway device
communicating to the cloud could be MQTT
good to be HTTP all the above work
Lanson typically IOT core to then be
consumed by by pub/sub once it's in
pub/sub it can be consumed by any of
those compute options God functions App
Engine compute engine kubernetes and
then land it in storage and both
analytics usually for analytics we're
seeing bigquery it's a very powerful
tool a lot of customers want to get
their hands on it so moving on to our
next set of projects this is analytics
and ETL style projects so we're going to
talk a little bit about some of the
trends we're seeing among those so this
first ETL customer they come to us as a
fortune 500 retailer they have their
online shopping model like all fortune
500 retailers do they have an option to
ship from store so their customers when
they're checking out they can ship from
store and when they're when they're
shipping from stores they can get it at
an expedited rate but the tough part for
our customer they didn't have a way of
tracking whether that order remains
profitable for them so they came to us
with the with the asked of helping them
define how can we determine if these
ship from store orders are profitable so
this one's a little bit longer you can
say it was three months instead of the
in the weeks range that some of the IT
projects were it's actually cuz our data
scientist he took a data dump of all of
their orders for like a year or two use
data lab to to essentially analyze all
the data and build an algorithm to help
determine if it was profitable so once
we were able to propose that to the
client the client approved it and we
were able to get moving on the on the
actual architecture itself so let's take
a look at what that architecture looked
like so as I mentioned you've got the
online ordering system so as soon as the
customer placed an order they landed it
on a Kafka server
from there we used a pub/sub connector
to land it in pub/sub and the reason
that we didn't bring it straight to
dataflow under certain environments you
certainly could do that this specific
customer had a firewall that we just
couldn't bypass so we line it in pub/sub
the air in the in with the connector as
a way to get it into data flow so from
there pub/sub consumed the the messages
off the topic ran its ETL job in this
case the algorithm that our data
scientists had created in the initial
phase and then we landed it in bigquery
for their analytics team and their
business users then consumed it via
tableau so after about three months this
retailer went from not being able to
determine whether or not an item was
profitable to being able to turn off the
ship from store item option on their
online shopping store for the for those
items next company here for ETL we're
gonna talk a little bit about it's a
medical device company they're located
in Minneapolis Minnesota they have a
companion app that they've published for
their further medical device helps the
users configure and monitor the activity
on their device and so they actually
built this with firebase to get it up
and running quickly they use fire store
and cloud storage on the back end and as
the research and development team
started to see the data coming in from
the users all the usage data Diagnostics
they realized that there was a big
opportunity for them to improve their
users experience by by looking at that
data what they ended up doing was coming
to us because in the medical industry
there's HIPPA and your R&D team can't
just get their hands on all that pH I
right that's that's that's an that's not
good so they came to us to build them a
sanitized pipeline that their R&D team
could then build build models off to
improve their their firmware on these
devices so after doing a review of their
app architecture as I mentioned fire
storm cloud storage really helped
move this along for weeks architecture
looked a little bit something like that
again you got your medical device it
landed it the app then wrote to fire
store so as soon as it wrote to fire
store document we put an on write cloud
function trigger on that data element
type in fire store so if that changed
whether it was a create and update a
delete event really anything it would
then trigger this cloud function do a
lookup in the cloud storage to find any
related data and then we found that
related data it would land a message on
pub/sub from here it's all the same
right so it lands in the data flow
consumes that message from pub/sub
performs its ETL in this case removing
all pH I and anonymizing the data and
then landing it in bigquery for their
analytics team to do with what they will
again as we look at these two ETL
projects hopefully you can start to see
some of the trends that you saw with the
IOT projects with the online ordering
system Kafka it acted as the event
trigger this is a streaming streaming
job right so an event trigger that then
landed in pops up for the message queue
that Len landed in data flow for ETL and
finally bigquery for analytics the
research and data models at fire store
and the cloud function that acted as the
event trigger from there everything's
the same again message queue is pub/sub
data flows your ETL tool big queries for
analytics so again that might look a
little something like this you have your
event trigger whatever that might be
could be a clock function could be the
the Kafka server could be anything
really then you line it in pub/sub
that's your messaging queue from there
you got your ETL pipeline and analytics
obviously there's some other additional
analytic options for analytics but as I
mentioned earlier bigquery is seems to
be the tool of choice amongst our
customers so one quick note up here
you'll see I also put all the compute
options under ETL pipeline if you think
back to our IT projects
both of those were also doing ETL with
cloud functions and Kubb right so you
can roll your own data flow is a great
tool if you if it fits your use case for
one and two if you're if you're trying
to get stood up quickly but but you
always have the option roll your own and
and the GCP compute services are a great
option for that so alright that's a lot
of architecture I went through that kind
of fast what is this well what's the
point of it all right so what we're
trying to say is there's a lot of ways
to accomplish what you're trying to do
and everyone has a unique problem you
all have your your own industry your own
company your facing your unique issues
and we don't want you to walk away
thinking that these are the only ways to
solve the problem because there's an
infinite number of ways that you can go
home and solve your issues well what
we're trying to say is that a unique
problem doesn't need to equal a unique
solution you saw two two examples of two
different companies that had very
different use cases but they benefited
from the same underlying architecture so
reference architectures are your friends
there's no shame and using it is tried
and tested and quite frankly there's no
extra credit for originality so you can
say both your organization time and
money all right so switching gears a
little bit you might get home from next
be ready to start down this next this
journey a new project come across the
list that looks a little something like
this
and then close your laptop because
you're a little bit overwhelmed so to
help curb that overwhelming feeling pass
it off to Ray over here he's going to
talk about some of these services that
we see most frequently
hey everyone I'm ray so that's that's a
big list 50 plus platform services API
is I think I got about 10 minutes so
we're gonna go into a deep dive all 50
of them don't worry I'll talk fast
get ready I'm just kidding but we are
gonna discuss a few of the favorites
that I have and stuff we use for
prototyping first I'm gonna start with
is IOT core it's Google's managed IOT
platform why do I like IOT core
well it's serverless so a few slides
back Patrick showed the IOT adapter that
we made and RabbitMQ that all ran on a
virtual machine required patching
management configuration plus building
our rabbit cluster that can handle a
million connected devices is not trivial
so IOT core will just scale up as you
know you connected me devices as you
want to it so let's talk about some of
the features of IOT core so without a
car
it supports device state configuration
and authentication it for for
communication with IOT core you can use
MQTT and HTTP and we all know about HTTP
let's talk about MQTT for a minute so
MQTT is a light rate messaging protocol
runs on TCP one of the differences
between HTTP and mqtt is that mqtt
device will typically make a connection
and hold it open to the server so ACB
usually you'll device will connect send
a bunch of headers negotiate encryption
and then disconnect with em PTT holds
connection open for as long as I can
could be ours by doing so you don't have
all that overhead so it uses a lot less
data especially when you're talking
about
you know device that maybe you're paying
for cell data on so and plus when you
when you have a device connected to via
mq DT you can push config to it so the
device has already subscribed to
configuration or command topics and so
what you do is you use an API call
anti ot car and it'll push config
directly to the device you don't have to
wait for that device to make it a
request to pull data so in IOT core is
really its its core purpose it's a
protocol bridge so with what we when you
connect to IOT core device sense data it
really ends up in pub sub so pub sub to
manage to real-time messaging service
for GCP so and IOT core data sends IOT
core device sends data and ends up in
pub sub and it's consumed by your
application your application is a
subscriber in pub sub so as I said
messages are published so you publish to
a topic and pub sub and again it doesn't
have to be used IOT core but you can use
pub sub for sending messages from
machine to machine so you'd be a
publisher publish to a topic and then
you could have subscribers so you have
multiple applications that could
subscribe to the same topic so you can
fan out your the data send it multiple
places there are other uses of pub sub
so we use pub sub commonly to distribute
work so in one of the other examples
that Patrick had he showed odd functions
daisy chaining via pub sub so you could
have one claude function has a lot of
work to do what you can do is it can
publish that to a pub sub topic you can
have many functions subscribed all doing
the same thing so you end up scaling
horizontally without doing a lot of work
so a couple of some of the features pops
up important pub/sub is it's a durable
message queue so if a message makes it
into pub/sub it's gonna stay there until
you pull it out or I think seven days it
will go then she throw it away
it has fan out fan and fan out support
so as you can see you can have multiple
publishers publishing the same topic you
can have multiple subscribers of the
same topic it's easy to integrate there
are client libraries for just about
every language it's very performant and
as I said is guaranteed delivery so when
a message is published into when when a
message is pushed into a pub/sub it's
waiting for a subscriber a subscriber
pulls that message it has to acknowledge
that it got the message otherwise
pub/sub will put it back in the queue
and wait for someone else to grab it are
a few caveats using pub/sub the message
order isn't guaranteed
so if order is important you'll have to
sort that out and your subscriber side
pub/sub supports at least once delivery
what that means is that it's guaranteed
to deliver it at least once but it could
deliver it more than once so you could
get duplicates you're also limited to
10,000 topics and 10,000 subscriptions
per GCP project so because of that
that's one reason you wouldn't have like
an end device published directly to
pub/sub you have more in ten thousand
devices publishing ten tales of topics
you're you don't do that so that that's
what use IOT core for next thing we'll
talk about is Club functions so we've
been using cloud functions a lot cloud
functions obviously they're serverless
and easy to deploy
you can trigger cloud functions a couple
different ways so if V&H to be request
so i think about just a typical web
service make a request in you could also
trigger a cloud function from a file
dropped in cloud storage so we will have
ETL pipeline that might have a cloud
function watching a cloud storage bucket
file shows up it it's automatically
triggered it knows about the file in
that cloud storage bucket they can grab
it and do some stuff with it
you can also trigger from pub/sub right
so unclog function can subscribe to a
pub sub topic you can also monitor a
fire store database so it can be
triggered from that so the changes in
the fire star database and a a cloud
function can be activated as well so we
in our inter prototypes we're using
cloud functions for you know as the
example he showed calling web hooks so a
pop function spins up that's hits some
other service and some other call
provider or wherever you know cloud
functions can easily read and write data
to fire star database cloud sequel
bigquery and of course you can send data
out at pub sub you can publish from
cloud function to an external service or
obviously another Club function you see
from the previous examples that we we
use cloud functions all over the place
next when I talk about bigquery so a big
create I love bigquery it graze on you
haven't used a big tree you should use
bigquery
so what one point I like to make about
big tree you don't need to have big data
to use bigquery so you can have just a
little data and bigquery so it's it's
great because if you you know who wants
to spin up a sequel server if you you
have a task you want to complete means
some place to store some data and query
later big Kriel work you could have you
know you could have a hundred rows make
a mate you basically your to set up
bigquery you you go into the UI and you
or you can do it via command line or API
you create a data set then you load data
into tables that's it
and like many of the GCP services it you
pay for what you use
so for bigquery you pay to query the
data you you get a lot of you there's a
lot of you'll you'll see later there's a
free tier for that but it's it's a it's
really relatively inexpensive especially
with small data sets and you pay a tiny
bit for a day of storage talking pennies
per gig and there's sin there's very
little configuration for a bigquery so
you wanna make a table you define the
table schema
then you create table and you load data
into it so as a couple of ways to load
data into bigquery you can stream the
data in so bigquery supports streaming
at you can stream up to a hundred
thousand rows per second into bigquery
so obviously it's very performant you
can also load be a batch job so think
about taking that like a JSON file or
CSV file put it in a cloud storage point
bigfry out it'll ingest it and and put
it in a table for you you query your
data out of bigquery using standard
sequel you can use common VI tools an
example we had was tableau but if you
walk through here you have you seen 20
different tools that you can query your
data with and a looker data studio you
can connect you can use to cloud cloud
data lab connects directly to bigquery
so data scientists data engineers spin
up a ipython notebook is what Cloud Data
lab is and I'll connect directly to big
free as well so one thing you wouldn't
use bigquery for is to store your data
if you're going to try and drive a
website like a real-time dashboard so
one thing you'll learn when you do a
query it can take it's gonna take a
couple seconds it doesn't matter if you
have you know 20 rows or 20,000 rows
it's a couple seconds to free that data
so you wouldn't want to wait to populate
a web page with data in bigquery you
want everyone run a query and bring back
like a report so so where would I store
my data if we wanted to to have it
available on a web page so we use cloud
firestore a lot works well with cloud
functions it's all integrated it's a
document database so you're storing key
value pairs no sequel so well commonly
use that to store configuration
application State stuff like that so it
supports real-time updating to is so web
developer can create a dashboard and
with very little effort you can have it
so that if a date if a value updates in
fires
it just automatically updates in your
dashboard so you look at a webpage you
don't have to do anything to pull data
it's automatically shows up up a value
so we'll use that we're building
dashboards showing application state or
status or counters things like that
we'll use firestore for that you can
backup your firestore data to cloud
storage as well so Google added support
for that so from there once you have
your data your firestore database you
can backup the whole thing pretty much
you can you can restore it back into
fire store so using it in the FIR you
could use that for disaster recovery so
not necessarily that you're some crashed
and you lost your data but more like if
somebody you over wrote your data or you
deleted it Union wanted to copy it to
restore - you can do that you can also
export that backup - big free and we've
done that quite a few times so if you
have this all this data in fire store
you can't really point an analytics tool
at fire store so but you can obviously
do it's a big free so Google has made a
feature of the fire store backup is that
you can restore that directly to
bigquery into your analytics on it we've
got customers that are doing that so
another thing we use a lot cloud storage
obviously cloud storages is it most
people know about that you can store
anything in cloud storage as long as
it's a file so a couple of things that
pop cloud storage they're interesting so
it's virtually unlimited right store as
much as you want in there you just pay
for what you use against pennies pennies
per gigabytes there is a five terabyte
file size limit though so if you know a
file bigger than five terabytes you're
gonna have to cut it up
it's got 11 9th of durability so you
you're not gonna lose your files there
in cloud storage and there are many
tools for managing your data in cloud
storage so you can use their client
libraries command line tools the the the
cloud console so when you get back home
and you start spinning up your projects
in the cloud console you can upload and
download files directly out of cloud
storage using the web UI as well there
are multiple storage classes and in
cloud storage so you may have heard
these regional buckets multi-regional so
when you when you create a bucket you
decide what type of bucket you want what
you want your storage to be so if you if
you pick a your multi-regional bucket
then you store data there google spreads
that data out it stores it punch pops
all over the place it puts the data
closer to your users so if you've got
users downloading data there'll be less
latency there you you wouldn't
necessarily want to do that if you're
doing analytics workloads though so they
have a also have a regional bucket so
you can imagine if you have a ton of
data you need to process you would you
know build your app to run and and
deploy it to like this US central well
you can deploy your your your bucket
data if your bucket also in US central
so you know so I can download faster and
it cost a little less we need to do
regional as well so they also have near
line cold line you probably heard of
those that's for less frequently
accessed data we we typically wouldn't
use that for prototype you usually store
now for backup
so talk a minute about cloud sequel I
like called sequel it's it's not is not
as easy stuff as bigquery but it's
certainly simple enough so we don't use
it as much for prototyping because it's
more configuration it's still a great
option to store your data currently
cloud sequel supports my sequel and
Postgres you can have a a sequel server
running in five clicks in the console
you can go into the GP cloud console
five clicks later you've got a sequel
server running sports all the stuff
you'd expect from a database service
high availability failover automated
backups playing time recovery you know
how dual storage increase so and and you
can have up to ten terabytes of storage
you connect to it just like any other
sequel so if you're already if you've
got an app that and that needs to
communicate with its my sequel or
Postgres server you connect to it the
same way if it's running the cloud
sequel or for a run on a virtual machine
or if it's running in your data center
so another thing that we that that we
been using a lot is cloud dataflow
so-called dataflow is a fully managed
service
it supports stream and batch processing
so the idea is with cloud dataflow is
that if you write your app correctly in
cloud dataflow you can use the same
logic whether it's streaming data in or
you're doing batch so it's server less
its auto scaling so the idea with cloud
dataflow is you submit a job it'll spin
up as many nodes as it needs to it'll
work until the job's done and then
they'll spin them down if you're doing
streaming it obviously won't do that
it'll it'll keep your streaming job
running forever or until you kill it so
common pattern for cloud dataflow is to
write data out to bigquery so we showed
that previously so you can also write
data out to cloud storage or pub/sub and
with the example that we had earlier we
were using dataflow to do data redaction
data enrichment so in that example data
flow was was reading data out of a big
tree table
it was reading flat files out of cloud
storage combining that data and then
redacting and pushing it back into a
different big free table and then from
there the guys could do their their
analytics on that clean data so firebase
hosting is our thing we use that's
pretty straightforward all it is is
static files so you we're building a
dashboard or there's some web component
to to to our prototype or balloon for
somebody we'll just you stick your HTML
Javascript CSS all that stuff can go in
a firebase post and it's really easy to
do supports custom domains all that all
that stuff the other thing we're using
is firebase authentication so
authentication isn't easy firebase
authentication makes it a little easier
so it's quick and easy to set up anyway
and it's a secure way to add off to your
app so when you're doing a prototype a
lot of times you
you know you'd want to spend a ton of
time building roles and permissions and
all the authentication that you would
have in a full-blown out firebase makes
it a lot easier to do that and in our
case instead of doing so you can with
firebase you can do there's I don't know
how many different ways to do
authentication its social and and all
this stuff well we usually do for a
prototype as we'll just enable user name
password so it's email password actually
so you can you can go into the console
and put emails and passwords in and
firebase takes care of that so they are
there hashing it and encrypting it and
storing it then we use API is to
authenticate the web app with that and
in a lot of cases we'll give that
firebase console since we're doing these
buildings for our customers
we'll give that project to the customer
and the customer can log into the
console and add their own users to it so
if they've got a UI built in to do that
right in firebase so back to the list I
obviously didn't go through all 50 of
them I just scratched the surface I
didn't get in a ton of detail there's so
much week Spence we could spend the
whole week talking about this stuff
right so but we will use a lot of these
other services as well obviously if it
makes sense there are a lot of different
ways to do the same thing and we four
prototypes we try and find the most
efficient quickest way to do it simplest
way to do it
Sarat spend a lot of time a lot of money
it's a big list so if you guys want to
geek out about any of these things later
we can stop by our booth I'll be glad to
talk to you about it as much as you want
so with that I'm gonna hand it back over
to Patrick let him talk for a little bit
[Applause]
all right before I move on to this next
slide here one more question for you
guys who likes free stuff if you don't
know about GCPs free tier you should
it's it's literally free hence free tier
it's really helpful when you're testing
out a new technology you don't have to
spend your own funds on it it's a good
way to play around with some of their
new services that they've announced here
today if you land on cloud.google.com
slash free it'll show you a list of
services when I was throwing this
presentation together that was the list
I can't promise that that is still the
same list Google reserves the right to
change that but you can go there it'll
show you all the details of what their
free tier is and some of the caveats but
a lot of the services ranges touched on
that we use in our prototypes everyday
are on that list right now right so you
have cloud fire storm cloud storage
pub/sub odd functions gke bigquery so
you can get a lot of value from the free
tier if you're leveraging it so a couple
of feature examples that I like to touch
on that I really find a lot of worth or
value in cloud functions one of them you
get two million invitations a month it's
a lot there are limitations on compute
time and some network egress but two
million implications is still nothing to
scoff at the other one would be bigquery
obviously we have a little bit of a
crush on bigquery but you can run a
terabyte of queries a month it's it's
nothing to nothing to scoff at either a
10 gigabyte storage limit still quite a
bit of data that you can query so what's
the point in all of this leverage you
free tiers and leverage the cloud native
services all the services that Ray went
over and that free tier that I was just
discussing they're meant to make your
life easier
help you save money and resource hours
something that I'm sure all of you could
appreciate in your day to days and also
it helps you focus on some more
strategic initiatives if you're able to
save that time you start focusing on
some more innovative innovative thoughts
that you that you and your team might
have so
that's a lot better than just focusing
on keeping the lights on alright last
thing for today do's and don'ts so we're
consultants obviously right we work with
a lot of organizations and we get to see
both the good the bad and the ugly so
some of these do's and don'ts are gonna
seem like complete no-brainers I wish
they were they're not always so if it is
a no-brainer for you that's good that
means you're doing it right but just
some some things to keep in mind
so the first do start with an idea and
formulate a plan simple right of course
but it's really easy to get excited
about your idea and just jump straight
into it but if you're doing that you're
probably not gonna end up very
successful you're gonna waste time
you're gonna win its budget hours no one
wants that so slow down a bit
define your approach figure out your key
use case requirements and then take
action that said don't over complicate
your approach it's a POC or it's a
prototype it doesn't need to be
complicated so just define it at a high
level define define what is going to
look like success so speaking of success
do define your success criteria if you
don't define your success criteria how
are you gonna brag about being
successful to your boss to your
colleagues anybody it also helps the
rest of your team stay focused on the
end goal if you have a success if you
don't have that success criteria how do
they know what they should be focusing
on so one important thing around that
success criteria it's not just
functional there is non-functional
requirements as well if you have
performance requirements if you have
security requirements those are things
that you should be considering in these
prototypes but don't confuse a POC or
your prototype with an MVP prototypes
kind of land in between PLC's and MVPs
as far as I'm concerned your MVP is
meant to be a market viable product
right so Minimum Viable Product but it's
it's its market ready POC is generally
internal facing you're trying to
determine feasibility of it maybe
testing new technology you prove
something
right so if there's success criteria are
identical you should probably take a
step back think about why they're
identical and figure out which one you
actually need to do if you're not
proving out a new concept and new
technology maybe you don't need to start
with the POC so either way
having the right success criteria is key
for the last one I've already alluded to
this set expectations with your key
stakeholders there's nothing worse than
getting to the end of a project
presenting what you have you're excited
you think it was a smashing success and
then your stakeholders just have this
blank look on their face they're
confused they're wondering where the
features they asked for were and it's
because you didn't set their
expectations properly or at least most
likely so if you can talk with them
early and often set those expectations
on what you're going to deliver when
you're going to deliver it that's going
to help you in the long run to get the
reactions that you want at the end the
other side of that coin don't be afraid
of changing course of strategy and I've
seen it a couple of times where in a
project owner the product owner doesn't
want to change their course because
they've already reported to the
stakeholders this is how we're gonna do
it and we're not gonna do it any other
way but they get down that path they
realize it's not a viable strategy and
they still continue down that path
you're wasting time and money that's not
good for you it's not good for your
company what you really should be doing
at that point is pausing reassessing
your other options
resetting expectations with your
stakeholders and changing your course
the the whole point of a POC or
prototype is to determine feasibility
right so if you find out that it's not
feasible there's there's no point in
continuing down that path that leads to
the last point of the day have a plan
communicate it and take action
the last one is key as well take action
a lot of projects fail because they
haven't started so don't forget don't
forget that last one all right so this
is about wrapping it up for us
just a couple of key points we've
already touched on these but if you
learn nothing else from us today
hopefully these can stick in your head
number one unique problems they don't
have to be unique solutions use
reference architectures
your friend leveraged the free tiers in
cloud native services to help you save
money and time and then have a plan
communicate that criteria and take
action
[Applause]
[Music]